[Applaus]
[Musik]
aus der Ferne betrachtet sieht camuns
aus wie immer
aber das Bild täuscht
so unberührt das dorfwerk so radikal hat
es sich verändert
[Musik]
gamuns liegt in der waldumnezia dem
größten Seitental des Bündner Oberlandes
der sussell war das Schicksal des
kleinen Dorfes wurde immer wieder mal
öffentlich diskutiert camuns ist ein
Beispiel für so viele bergbauerndörfer
die sich in der letzten Jahrzehnten
dramatisch entfällt haben
1976 berichtet das Schweizer Fernsehen
[Musik]
sie haben weniger als 100 Einwohner und
sie tun sie schwer mit ihren Pflichten
die 46 Zwerg Gemeinden in Graubünden
sterben diese Gemeinden Freiheit Ziehens
zum Beispiel gamuns im lugnet
das ist der Gemeinde vollkommen uns die
rotenhäuser das sind bewohnt der grüne
Häuser das sind Ferienhäuser
das sind leere das ist unsere Kirche und
das ist unsere Schulen
in ganz
Einwohner
[Musik]
Leere
Schülerin von damals 50 Jahre später
heute hat gamuns noch 27 Einwohner die
meisten Häuser sind in fremden Händen
auch das Geburtshaus von gordilia de
Rossbach
aber unsere Mutter hatte noch rundherum
Blumen
aber natürlich
verkauft das geht alles weg langsam und
ja
uns wird langsam
rechts im Bild Elia mit 13 Jahren der
jüngste Einwohner und das einzige Kind
in Kamenz heute freut er sich über
Besuch
er
[Musik]
wäre schön
und jetzt also und er bin in Ruhe
plötzlich sind 3 4 Familie mit ganz viel
die Familie zwei bis vier Kinder
im Nachbardorf das naus gibt's Bewegung
nebst zwei Familien mit Kindern sind
auch einige junge Leute ins Dorf
gekommen
Johanna Jan und Leander wollen bleiben
und etwas bewegen
Jan Hermle wuchs in Malans auf er
studiert Geographie und ökologische
Landwirtschaft
wir hoffen dass mehr junge Leute da sind
das ist Treffpunkt geht und dass dort du
suchst du denn wieder neue Initiativen
und Projekt entstand wie zum Beispiel
Konzert oder mal das Theater
diskussionsartig zu meiner politische
Thema oder
genau richtig
Leander Albin ist Schreiner Lehrer und
Musiker er ist intessen aus aufgewachsen
war ein paar Jahre weg und lebt und
arbeitet seit zwei Jahren wieder hier
unbedingt weg
dass ich Mitgliedern
ist und so Sachen
und doch bist du circa
ja
[Gelächter]
das Gefühl statt
fühle mir eine sehr wohl mit ja mit der
mit dem Kultur oder Gebot oder was man
alles so machen kann so großwege ist und
so Sachen ich weiß es gibt mir viel um
die lerne sehr viel mit der Zeit
bin oft so bis zerrissen sie zwischen
der Welt
für die Menschen
eigentlich
sie so wenig
mitgemacht haben und kann vielleicht
nicht so viel bewirken
ein selbstbestimmtes Leben im Einklang
mit der Natur das ist heute ein starker
Trend vor allem bei jungen Menschen im
Unterland die Luzernerin Johanna horny
arbeitet in Weiß als Heilpädagogin
was macht ihr da sondern
in Kontakt kommen
jetzt gibt es auch ein paar junge die
zugezogen sind ja ihre WG befindet sich
gleich da hinten
[Musik]
es ist schön wenn sich neue Leute hier
niederlassen das auch im Dorf wieder
etwas Leben ein bevor uns hier noch
alles abstirbt
[Gelächter]
sie sind höflich so geht es gut
das ist eine ganz andere Angelegenheit
sie sind für den Wolf ich hingegen nicht
weil ich ja mein Vieh habe abgesehen von
der Partie haben sie keine Tiere und die
sind auch mehr ein Hobby
ich habe auch schon mit Johanna
gesprochen aber am besten fängt man
damit gar nicht an sonst diskutiert man
ohne Ende
sie sehen das ganz anders
das ist das Haus der Großmutter von Gott
Delia Derungs es ist 320 Jahre alt und
die Renovation ist ihr großes Projekt
was ist das hier unter diesen Brettern
wurde damals isoliert
[Musik]
wurde damals zu Isolierung verwendet
auch früher verstanden die Leute ihr
Handwerk
haben eine gute Millionen Schweizer
Franken in den Umbau investiert
zu viele Erinnerungen sind mit diesem
Haus verknüpft es sollte nicht in fremde
Hände kommen
Corona zieht halt schon zeigt oder es
ist so das ganz viel Leute
aber das ist jetzt nicht drum machen wir
das sondern wir das wirklich husisch von
der Großmutter will mir wie sie wurzeln
[Musik]
was schön sie ist dass man vor allem
auch große Freiheit
wir sind nicht immer behütet worden mit
der Vera mit dem semmi und mit dem
Stefan haben wir den verstecken fleder
ist eines der Mädchen die einst mit
codilia verstecken spielte bis heute
verbringt sie ihre Ferien ja für Jahr in
Kamenz
die Ernte sind verschlossen
der geblieben ist der Bauer näht sich
dem Pensionsalter 40 Jahre lang waren
seine Frau und er tagtäglich eingespannt
keiner der beiden Söhne will den Betrieb
übernehmen nun suchen sie einen Pächter
betrieben
[Musik]
vor 50 Jahren ernährte die Viehzucht 14
kinderreiche Familien heute hat kam uns
noch drei Bauern dieser
Konzentrationsprozess ging auch in der
scheinbaren lugnezer bergöle nicht ohne
Streitigkeiten ab der Boden ist begrenzt
und die Agrarpolitik fordert immer
größere Betriebe
[Musik]
lauft lauft ja langsam auf der
aus
und der kam von der Boden
ziemlich viel hinkriegen
vor Jahren gab es hier nur Bauern und am
Alpabzug war das ganze Dorf beteiligt
heute dominieren ein paar Maschinen das
Bild
[Musik]
und die Bauern sind eine kleine
Minderheit
[Musik]
zwei Betriebe gleichzeitig zu führen
langfristig gesehen ist das sicher nicht
gut für die Gesundheit
ich habe auch rund 30 Hektaren mehr will
ich gar nicht sonst Schufte man sich ja
noch zu Tode letztlich geht es um
Lebensqualität und Freude am Beruf hat
man zu viel zu tun bleibt gar kein Raum
mehr für die Freude
im Laufe der 1960er 70er Jahre kam immer
mehr Bauern die Freude an der
Landwirtschaft abhanden einer nach dem
anderen verließ das Dorf
ja der Junge war intelligent sind
kriegen ein bessere stellhüter bessere
Existenz als toll
auch die jungen Frauen wollen nicht wie
ihre Mütter Leben zum ersten Mal in der
Geschichte von camuns haben Sie die
Freiheit über ihre Zukunft selber zu
entscheiden
[Musik]
dass die intelligenter die wandern ab
wir lernen im Beruf und wandern aber das
hätten natürlich auch ganz wenige
intelligente die doblieben und
Landwirtschaft führen aber das sind halt
zu wenig um irgendwie ein Gemeinde
lebensfähig zu halten
[Musik]
die günstigen Preise ermöglichen auch
Familien aus bescheidenen Verhältnissen
den Erwerb eines Feriendomizils in den
Bergen
[Gelächter]
als Linus Liebers 1991 nach Kamenz zieht
hat man im Dorf seit 14 Jahren keine
Geburt mehr verzeichnet
meine Frau und die mit zwei Kinder sind
im eine
90s Glück gehabt dass man
stell kreiert zu meiner Familie
dass man
Posthalter und Kanzlei gemacht hat
postleiter und Kanzlei hätte den 100%
Stärke meine Frauen die mir hinter das
teilt denn die stellen sie 40% Kanzlei
gemacht und die 60% der Posthalter
also mit mir mit meiner Familie vier
Personen haben wir praktisch 10% von der
Bevölkerung gestellt oder und dann haben
wir selber aktiv
dann doch noch ein paar Familie dazu und
der Willi Land nicht
50 Kindergarten aber alle halt im
gleichen Alter so wie Minimum ungefähr
und das ist dann halt genau das passiert
die werden älter und Flüge los und mehr
alte Liebe zurück und jetzt hoffen wir
wieder das ist irgendetwas ja
auch Koordinate uns war damals gegangen
die Schülerin die im Fernsehfilm mir
Dorf so souverän erklärte hat im
Unterland Karriere gemacht die
ausgebildete Logopädin ist eine gefragte
Spezialistin für Autismus ja es
wir sind auch sehr gern da so schön wie
es da ist aber die Berge die
das einfache Leben vielleicht auch
die Ruhe nicht so eine Hektik vielleicht
auch ja
Derungs noch in Oetwil an der Limmat
zusammen mit ihrem Mann Daniel katomen
er ist Marketingleiter eines global
tätigen beleuchtungsunternehmens
[Musik]
teilte Daniel
ja jetzt schon also vor das paar Jahre
ist für ihn noch
weg das ist das ist schon so weg vom
Schuss und alles ja und dann haben wir
noch und dann mit der Jahre hat gemerkt
wie schön das kann man sich wie schön
das ist das mit Herzschlag und dann
hätte gesagt doch jetzt bin ich soweit
doch wir könnten und das freut mich
natürlich
funktioniert aber das ist ja auch normal
das ist von mir immer wieder feststellen
und jetzt denke je länger
trotz der lange Distanz und nein die
jetzt weg sind von Beruf sind jedes
Wochenende jedes mal wenn du Ferien
das ist Mentalität das ist Kultur es ist
Landschaft und alles und du musst mir
sagen
spürbar also ich würde
negativ gegenüber dem was man da hinein
aber sie ist einfach Kraft aber wenn der
Film ist wohl und du mich jetzt neu
liegend dass mir so die Kreis wieder
zieht
[Musik]
auch im Winter bleibt camuns mit der
Welt verbunden
aber die Natur wagt sich in der kalten
Jahreszeit noch näher ans Dorf
[Musik]
Theophil Derungs ist zufrieden er hat
einen Pächter für seinen Betrieb
gefunden
sind sie Frau liebe Freunde
Problem aber
vielleicht ja
gleich neben Theophil derungsheim steht
das fragliche Haus es gehört der
Gemeinde und ist seit Jahren an
Unterländer Gäste vermietet nun sollen
sie eine Bauernfamilie Platz machen das
sind jedes Praktikum praktisch jedes
Wochenende
mehr sehen
Familie
[Musik]
in tessenaus hat Familie Albin einen
sanften agrottourismus aufgebaut
wir treffen Edith Albin die vor 30
Jahren aus Deutschland zugewandert ist
die Gäste werden nicht das Fremde
wahrgenommen sie sind vielmehr
eingeladen den bergbauernalltag aus der
Nähe kennen zu lernen und als Unterkunft
dient das alte Schulhaus
[Musik]
im Winter meistens und
[Gelächter]
michaelsdorf und mir suchen
kulturelle
Motivationen sind
und es gibt immer wunderschöne intensive
Gespräch und Erlebnis miteinander
aber Familie Albin hat Ziele die über
den Agrotourismus hinausgehen
[Musik]
um genau das zu ermögliche dass Menschen
junge Menschen wirklich zu süß ins Dorf
kommen
zum permanente wohne also nicht als
Zweitwohnsitz sondern als permanente
Bewohner
Jahn und Leander haben im Dorf eine
Bleibe gefunden in einem der Häuser der
Familie Albin
also
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ja so
so schnell kann es so wie du sie also
das wenn ich alleine
Gemeinschaft mit verschiedenen Leuten
verschiedene Menschen wo ganz andere
hintergründet
großpotenzial zum
und das finde wir spannend
[Musik]
dir hat sich inzwischen einiges
verändert der Innenausbau ist soweit
fortgeschritten das kordelia Derungs und
ihr Mann einziehen konnten
also was ganz speziell ist ist einfach
mal ist ganz einfach aber
man merkt einfach funktioniert ganz
anders man kochen mit Freunden
natürlich und was ich natürlich jetzt
auch wieder angefangen haben indem
Ambiente wo mich doch sehr inspiriert
Musik machen
[Musik]
eigentlich ganz viel Ideen
für Familie mit Autismus je nachdem
Gaststätten für die wo mit dem velode
gefahren
oder so aber was ist los geht's alles
aber das ist auch noch nicht das so rief
das kann sie deshalb natürlich permanent
da wohnt wenn ich je nachdem
mache den werde das auch so das Familie
den Täterin die Wohnung aber ja das ist
noch nicht ganz richtig
in den letzten Jahren haben zwei
Faktoren die Nachfrage nach altem
Baubestand in Berggebieten enorm
gesteigert die Zweitwohnungsinitiative
welche Neubauten viele ortsverhindert
und die corona-pandemie welche eine
veritable Fluchtbewegung Richtung alten
ausgelöst hat die Hauspreise gingen
durch die Decke
ist eins der wenigen Dörfer die noch
nicht gänzlich ausverkauft sind
der Zweitwohnungsanteil ist hier mit 30%
relativ klein
auf Initiative der WG trifft sich die
Einwohnerschaft von Hessen aus zum
Gedankenaustausch wie soll es
weitergehen mit ihrem Dorf
die Wunschliste benennt das wichtigste
Defizit
und ich kenne viele wo würdet Berge
ziehen aber halt einfach nicht
bezahlbare Wohnungen gibt also für so
jungilith wollen möglich
eine Gruppe junger Leute trifft sich in
Terrassenhaus um Lösungsmöglichkeiten zu
suchen sie haben Fachleute aus der Stadt
eingeladen
wenn es um Geld geht schaut jeder
meistens für sich das gilt auch für die
Einheimischen Hausverkäufer
besteht aus denen wo sie vielleicht
verkaufen aber wenn sie nachher gesehen
ist einfacher wurde es als Ferienhaus
kauft dreifache Zahlen irgendwen gesehen
sind sie ja gut also das kann man mit
dem Geld machen und dann sehen sie auch
gut das ist so viel und dann ist doch ja
das Hörgerät
es hat eigentlich noch
nicht so viel Tourismus wenn man keine
Skilift haben und es ist mega coole
Leute
umlegende dürfen
schöner schön und Leute einfach
gemeint involvieren das weiß jetzt zum
Beispiel überhaupt noch
Daniel Soler ist Präsident der Gemeinde
lunezia
ihm ist das Problem durchaus bewusst je
höher der Anteil an meist leer stehenden
Zweitwohnungen desto rückender der
Mangel an bezahlbarem Wohnraum für
Einheimische wir sind jetzt da zum aktiv
Land Server kaufen
selber bauen
Bilder und mit deiner Zimmer das
realisiert und den für wirklich
junge Familie zur Verfügung stellen
er
[Musik]
unterstützen
ich glaube da müssen wir einmal müssen
wir wir hören sie vor zum das machen wir
wir sollen das Aussehen und ich glaube
das immer mit offener sie sollen
ziemlich hoch und dann glaube ich wenn
das
Orte Konzept hätten
wir bereits
unterstützen so so Sachen
[Musik]
das sind bemerkenswert neue Töne
noch vor wenigen Jahren wäre eine
Wohngemeinschaft junge Leute von
auswärts wohl auf wenig Verständnis
gestoßen
[Musik]
oder mir ja was ist das für den Ort aber
was ich jetzt so feststelle ist dass
Bevölkerung auch mit dem Weg
zugverfielen mit mit der endvölkerung
sehr offen wurde sind gegenüber neue
Menschen
wirklichen Wandel geht und in der
Gesellschaft kennt sich einiges
verändert so dass mir gesehen wow das
könnte gleich noch eine Chance haben
hat von der Gemeinde guten Bescheid
bekommen sein junges Pächterpaar kann
ins Haus der Gemeinde einziehen
die Dorfbevölkerung von camuns nimmt zu
zum letzten Mal bringt er mit seiner
Frau die Heuernte ein und erinnert sich
und nichts übernommen
dennoch noch immer den dolland kriegt
früher hatten immer
z.B mit dem Meer gemacht
[Musik]
und jetzt so wenn
den kann man schon
man sprechen
aber das Dorfleben im eigentlichen
eigentlich
weniger unter den Handel große Kontakte
hätten nein
[Musik]
auf dem Friedhof
will unter anderem jungen Leuten aus dem
Unterland das Probewohnen im Berggebiet
ermöglichen Schlafzimmer
als ständige Wohnraum
[Musik]
sind oder glaub sie können sie trotzdem
können willkommen heißen und
ja
ich glaube das Beste draus machen
[Musik]
Andreas Albin gefällt das intessen aus
so wie es ist die WG beobachtet er mit
Interesse aber auch mit einer leisen
Skepsis
schon
recht wenn Leute zuziehen
die machen aber auch nicht viel für die
Dorfentwicklung
sie leben einfach und haben vielleicht
nicht die Mittel eine Familie mit
Kindern aufzuziehen
so entwickelt sich das Dorf kaum weiter
wenn nur ein paar wenige kommen viel
ändert sich meiner Meinung nach nicht
es sind aber junge die kommen
ja jung sind sie
so bleiben sie vielleicht im Dorf Länge
erhalten
kann sein dass sie länger bleiben wenn
sie nicht plötzlich wieder verschwinden
derweil versuchen Jan und lernen eine
alte Maschine zum Leben zu erwecken sie
bereiten ein Theaterstück vor in welchen
der alte heuwende als Perkussionist
auftritt
viel es ist so gut im Moment und gleich
ist mir bewusst alles für andere sich ja
immer also es ist
dankbar nicht so viel Zukunft
immer solche
also für mich mache
in camuns wird Großmutters renoviertes
Haus eingeweiht
also
zusammen sein können aber noch mehr
freut uns die tolle Arbeit die ihr
geliefert habt
vielen Dank
[Applaus]
Arbeit
und das sind 320 Jahren
dieser Backofen lieferte einst das Brot
für 30 Hausbewohner heute gibt's Pizza
[Gelächter]
diese Generation und es hat typische
analog die alte Substanz aufgekauft
werden und umbaut werden dass sie
natürlich
jungge Generationen junggefamilie die er
wenn dir Wetter war noch nie nach dem
findet sie gar keine Möglichkeit zum
Wohnen sie das zum Teil es wird oder als
kaufen
Widerspruch also zwei Pole was ich
irgendwie im Weg stöhnt und das ist
schon sehr große Frage wo politisch
wirtschaftlich muss gelöst werden von
mir jetzt
dazu passieren
unser letzter Besuch führt uns ans
Kulturfestival Quatsch dass die WG von
hessenhaus zusammen mit vielen
freiwilligen von auswärts seit 2018
organisiert
das kulinarische Angebot ist vegan die
Preise sind nicht bindend
[Musik]
und das ist zugänglich ist auch
gar kein Geld
[Musik]
und sich das Ganze anschauen und
genießen
sich ein riesige freut sie überzügelt
mich wirklich mit dem Herzblut mit dem
Sie bitte sach sind und den
Gemeinschaftssinn Frauen und
gemeinschaftskreis und was die auf die
Baustellen großartig also ob das den
beliebt wissen wir nicht aber das sind
neuer Schwung ohne nicht und das da bis
neues keinen Stau dass ich das zeigt das
Festival und wir sind da sehr offen und
sehr hoffnungsvoll auch ja
die rege Beteiligung aus dem Unterland
weckt Hoffnungen wird es Joana Jan und
Leander gelingen auf Dauer neues Leben
nach dessen Haus zu bringen
in camuns wird sich in den nächsten
Jahren wohl nicht viel ändern
[Musik]
das Dorf ist ausverkauft